not that anybody asked but do you ever
wonder why the old light bulbs get hot
and the new LED light bulbs don't
the old light bulbs 90 of the energy you
were paying for ninety percent of the
wattage was coming out in a band of
light that you cannot see it was
completely useless to you and what band
was that infrared and we detect infrared
as warmth and in the Extreme as
something very hot that can burn you
so what LEDs do is take all the energy
you need and want in a light bulb and
put it all in the visible part of the
spectrum
well if that's what it's doing it
doesn't need 60 watts 100 watts to do it
it only needs three Watts five Watts at
most 10 watts because all that energy is
going into visible light welcome
to the present
Welcome To The Future